the money will allow some closed clinics
to reopen
all across the community eight news now
reporter madison kimbrough joins us live
in the newsroom tonight with the latest
details on this
madison yes sasha a non-profit
organization called dentaquest donated
25 thousand dollars to the dental school
providing care for women children
veterans
and homeless individuals and now with
this massive donation they can provide
more care for those in need dentaquest
an oral health care company has donated
25 thousand dollars to unlv's dental
school
to help with their women's clinic
providing dental work for those in need
the clinic works directly with the shade
tree a local organization that provides
safe shelter to homeless and abused
women and children
in crisis services like these are
crucial especially for women and
children that are now in a vulnerable
state
and need help to meet some of the most
basic human needs
this allows us to provide direct care
they come in they're identified
we appoint them our students provide
this care
so they don't have to worry about these
costs our faculty give their saturdays
and they're here
helping monitor and help teach if the
clinic determines that someone needs
more than just a standard cleaning
they will be directed to their main
clinic free of charge
this is the biggest amount dentaquest
has ever donated to the school
a donation dr garcia says they are
extremely grateful for
they have been involved before now to
the level
this is huge for us this is big 25 000
and remember we have reduced rates
at the dental school so it's not
directly at the full cost of private
practice
so that allows us to do more with the
funds we have the women's clinic started
10 years ago
and since then they have done over a
thousand procedures helping these women
and children gain their confidence and
smile again
they've done 1 600 procedures since
2011. so procedures may be a crown
a cleaning an extraction a filling so
when you think about that that's about a
value over that many years of over three
hundred thousand dollars
if you would like to donate to the
clinic we will have a link to their page
up on our website
any amount helps and once again if you
would like to donate we will have all
that information up on our website for
you to help
reporting live in the newsroom madison
kimbrough 8 news now